As you know, this week we are celebrating beauty
both inside and out.
And something I truly cherish in my life
are all of my beautiful relationships.
And I find that one of the best ways
to nourish those relationships
is with a handwritten card.
And so I thought I'd reach out to a few past guests,
and I got to team up with Hallmark to make it happen.
I love Hallmark!
Hallmark's real stories collection
is actually about all of life's moments.
And it doesn't have to be a holiday
for you to buy and send a card to someone.
This is a 365 opportunity to show support,
encouragement, and appreciation to someone
you are just getting to know
or have loved your whole life and everyone in between.
This is from the support collection
and I wrote it to my friend Justin,
and it says be as kind to yourself,
as you are to everyone else.
And I have to say, he is someone who has saved lives.
That's how good he is to everyone else.
He is 18 year old, Justin Gavin, from Brooklyn, New York.
He saw a burning car on the street
with a mother and her three children inside,
and without hesitation he risked his own life
to pull each one of them out of that burning car
into safety.
We found out that you're a fan of the Brooklyn Nets
and they wanted to say thank you too.
So we have hooked you all up.
We're getting you season passes.
I wrote, dearest Justin, I'm so excited
for your season tickets to the Brooklyn Nets.
Have so much fun... And remember...
be as good to you, as you are to everyone else.
Lots of love...
Your friend Drew.
I love it. Thank you, Drew. And I hope to see you soon.
And this card is from the appreciation collection
and it was totally my favorite.
And I thought, hmm, who should I send this to?
Oh, Jonah. Jonah Larson is a crochet prodigy
and a good friend of mine.
He authored his first book at 11
and he helped create a new library
in the Ethiopian village in which he was born.
He's since become a correspondent for the show
and does so much, including book reviews.
This card says, I love you this much.
And it's got the cutest little dinosaur
and these beautiful metallic hearts.
And it just really spoke to me.
So I sent it to my dear friend, Jonah Larson
Dearest Jonah, it's true. I love you so very much.
I can't wait to continue our journey together
to do good in this world.
You are my inspiration and the best partner ever.
See you soon.
Your friend, Drew.
Thank you so much for this letter Drew. It made my day.
But I want to thank you for being
a really wonderful crochet friend of mine.
Thank you so much, Drew.
This is from their encouragement collection.
And I thought, hmm, who should I send some encouragement to?
I know my friend, Hailey, who was on our show
with Carrie Underwood, and she has a very incredible program
where she sells bracelets for good.
I told my mom, I wanted to sell them
and raise money for one of the hospitals.
Because of our show, it upped her game.
And she went from like a few thousand dollars
to almost $50,000.
So I wanted to encourage Hailey to keep going.
Dearest Hailey, you are doing such important work
and yet you are the sweetest young lady!
And you are truly showing the power of what is possible.
I am sending you lots of love
and encouragement to keep you going.
Your friend, Drew.
Drew Barrymore!
Thank you so much for thinking of me.
I love it. Your friend, Hailey.
(applause)
I can't handle the level of sweetness. I really can't.
And starting today, Hallmark is giving away
1 million cards to help you connect
with those that you care about.
Go to hallmark.com/sharecaring
to request your free three card pack while supplies last.
And BFFs, because we want you to make the people
in your life feel special right away.
You are all getting $50 Hallmark gift cards.
So break out those pens and pour your heart out.
(upbeat music)